okay so uh in this back drill
i'm i'm very dynamic and i move out of
the way and i move out of the way
when i do the second move you move once
you feel that he's got you
on that beat okay so it's it's not like
blowing up here
he's gonna get me okay i move when he
when he lines up so he drops it back
and we're here and right when i feel him
get a beat on me i'm already moving so
he's trying to get me
this right here all of them okay so
right when you feel yourself with the
target you're removing
that's the drill
here
he should never be touching me that's
the drill there should be no close calls
i'm here this is not it
[Music]
okay try it again
okay so when i kick and i'm gonna move
look
i'm gonna regain that distance
uh i'm not gonna boom he goes by and i'm
good here
so in this footwork you'll see out
see going back light on your feet
okay try it again
[Music]
so
and i'm in here
[Music]
ketchup
so i'm going in boom
move okay now he's gonna turn okay
so i'm i want that i leave him on the
curve
then he's going to turn again that's
when i enter
so here that's how you get behind me his
energy keeps going
you know
okay let's go so i'm going to kick
and he's going to try for a clip you see
so i kick boom he goes home i move out
of the way
and he's time for it again that's that's
my move okay
uh if you want you could go with the jab
and he'll follow it back in it's going
to be the same thing
it doesn't matter okay so this is just
to work on our dynamic
movement boom
if they if they get that pincher grip
you see defend it move out of the way
it goes again you see i passed the arm
make it work don't get stuck
with this arm there okay
don't let him grab you
[Music]
but he has to try to get that
okay let's go
so
[Music]
right here don't open up for the
technique any more than you have to so
boom brighter bone
back pedal very relaxed whoa
tight again nice and smooth both rolls
so note on the
on the technique it's
here okay forearm
bridge of the nose forearm bridge of the
nose
not hand on the chin
or by the mouth area you don't want him
to bite you
and not on the neck because you don't
have the hinge of the head
to help you so he's able to do this part
he's coming in whoa i hit
there and you can see the tilt already
so boom tilt and it's not a smash
because as i feel the resistance of his
body
i'm going to tencon around it
then i'm down it'll turn his face
and that's what i shove down so all that
hit
here you're going to feel the resistance
of his mask and you yield
by going around it you're now on the
side of this
head and that's what i pull
and keep in that position pattern which
is the tilting of his body
pull here around him there's the tilt
stay there it's here you see like cookie
home
but you're here like this oh
okay so try to remember you only have an
emery spiral
and then you only have this inverse this
is the outer spiral those are your only
two arm movements
in your aikido and the inner spiral is
going to require that my wrist and elbow
move through the
yin and yang phases of my body so if my
elbow is starting at the
yang line and it's going to move in
until my elbow is at least at the in
line if not to the transition line
between the ending on my
spine line okay so as you're going with
the technique we'll just do the
technique here
i don't want to bring my elbow here my
elbow is staying on the young line where
that where it came from so there's no
effect so
this hand has to move so that the elbow
is coming
towards that transition line of my spine
how then does it do the movement because
i'm not
here i'm moving around do you see
so the technique is the same movement of
edema
but i'm not maintaining that same
relationship
so with my arm i'm moving around it's
doing the same spiral
same inward
moving around
i'm not going to go around him but it's
going to go in
not bend here so the elbow stays with my
yarn line
it's going in boom
okay try it again
[Music]
so
you